Il y a 30 ans, la NASA a lancé une
capsule temporelle dans l'espace dans l'espoir de
contacter la
vie extraterrestre. Je crois qu'une force vitale extraterrestre
a envoyé
des jeux vidéo
pour
nous attaquer, c'est
logique, nous n'avons jamais été confrontés à une menace comme
celle-ci avant d'avoir besoin d'une expertise en jeux vidéo.
Sam Brener  Champion du monde Pac-Man,
quoi de neuf, Bludo Lamin avec le
score le plus élevé jamais enregistré sur le mille-pattes, également
connu comme votre pire cauchemar, le roi des plantes P
de Donkey
Kong, est-ce vrai, oh
ouais, trouve le modèle, je ne connais pas le
modèle, la seule façon de vaincre
Pac.  -L'homme est avec des fantômes, tu veux
des fantômes, ce sont tes fantômes, allons sur
[Musique],
ne le dis à personne, j'ai tué le
Schtroumpf,
Pac-Man a 10 secondes pour
nous manger, tu as ça si nous savons que
la
fin du monde est la nôtre.  pour leur mener la bataille
âne k
un jeu dans lequel tu es nul
puis-je te présenter le créateur de
Pac-Man Professeur Rani qu'est-ce que tu
fais je vais lui parler c'est mon fils
bonjour mon doux petit garçon regarde comme
tu as grandi  c'est si gentil il est si gentil
tu es un bon
garçon, que quelqu'un arrête ça